hey how's Gomes my name is Jimmy Serrano
Gunn gonna be at the April in less than
an hour well let's make some sure okay
well let's get to it then I don't know
what the [ __ ] that was
we're playing wax on wax off super
realistic version cuz I'm gonna join in
with half here and gonna wax my chest
cuz it's getting a little hairy there oh
yeah let's get naked with half so puff
I'm gonna let you begin let's put one
there take out the double wax strip and
rub it between your hands
oh it's on now
great I immediately regret this so much
alright
Hasselhoff you my man you do it first
baby are you knitting a jumper
don't patronize me Hasselhoff I can do
it too
well I'm a man like Hasselhoff now oh
it's still sticky let's place this one
here you're gonna look good as hi
Hasselhoff just remember that all right
Hasselhoff you go first man alright
Hasselhoff I take it you did one more
Hasselhoff no way oh it's just pain ah
[ __ ] mother [ __ ] ah oh this is the
manliest thing I ever done I fear that
it's time for a nipple oh my god
it's there
let's do Hasselhoff snips beauty comes
with the price we're so wise my great
senpai Hasselhoff Hasselhoff Hasselhoff
Hasselhoff Hasselhoff Hasselhoff hi slow
hands look fassl off Oh Jer hush love
oh that burn oh my god alright
Hasselhoff you ready no pain no gain
you are so wise as you are hairless or
Harry I don't pooh-pooh oh I should ha
pass it off pass it off Hasselhoff
Hasselhoff Hasselhoff Oh shake it out
[ __ ] laugh man I don't want to do it
anymore mom
no pain no gain that's a lot hustle up
ah laughs man oh I'm bleeding I'm
[ __ ] bleeding
alright that's it no when the red ready
blue comes to show then it's time to say
good the room really something else
wasn't it they were like for a
Hasselhoff and my beautiful chest and I
will see you in the next one suggest me
another challenge and um you know I'm
all about the gaming realism so that's
all for now stay awesome bris hold the
[ __ ] on alright I got that
[ __ ] Henrietta's yalla Fichte no
no